on the mound jacob junas 13 of 18 first
pitch strikes in his last outing he's
got what it takes there's no question
about it the four seamer gonna have to
be careful with that uh with this team
because they are really good at fast
balls in the middle keep it on the edges
eddie rosario batting fourth tonight d.h
it's the 2-2 pitch
swinging in a miss he got him with a
fastball up and in and junis has his
first strikeout no score in the third
buckston batting then kepler then
polanco
swinging a drive into left center field
that's it deep back it goes and that is
gone so buxton's bat stays out
back-to-back knights with a home run and
the twins take a one-nothing lead that
ball was down in the zone watch it
slider you see how it just
stayed right over the middle and
byron puts a real nice swing on it
barrels it up a little deep and boy he
crushed it devin smeltzer on for the
third time this season tonight marks his
first start picked up the win in relief
out of the bullpen on sunday schmelzer
so far in four and two thirds inning six
runs both of those came in his 2020
debut against the white sox mikel franco
leads off the royals third inning
they're down one nothing on a buxton
homer the over shift three on the left
side of the infield
oh nice it's that one whale into left
field and that's going to get to the
wall
franco's got his 10th extra base hit he
is safe and the royals have a leadoff
man on in scoring position here in the
bottom half of the third big league
hitter is going to barrel that that's a
change up and it is meaty looking i'm
telling you that i mean this is when
that ball sits in the middle like that
you just hope you don't hit it at the
third baseman pretty good guy in this
situation and nikki lopez the royals
have some options both corners are in
well it gets the bunt down their only
play will be first base smeltzer throws
him out franco to third
he just have to be a it's a little bit
patient here and look for a pitch that
he can get up underneath
and then he singles to left field and
the royals have tied it
how about nick heath matheny told him
before the game or actually yesterday
before his start hey look just just put
just go compete and you're at bats you
may not win them but you want to compete
and show yourself well there's a
fastball right there and a handsy swing
beautiful that is all you want to do
infield in like that and the royals have
it tied up 1-1 and here's whit
merrifield
1-2 strike three swinging so smeltzer
strikes out mirrorfield the big out
there two down as he chased down to the
bring up marwan gonzalez who singled his
first time up
first pitch swinging hits it high in the
air deep center field long run and he's
gonna look up and go
hey marwyn gonzalez solo home run and
the twins back on top two to one
he said this is a tough part to hit it
out of but marwan connected for his
second homer he made this change in the
off-season and said it's been a huge
adjustment for him but with pretty good
results see drianza there grounded out
well hard as first time up
and then he goes with an off speed pitch
confidence after giving up a home run on
the
changeup he came back with a changeup
and strikes out adrianza one down
quickly here in the board and that'll
bring up mcbroom room sharing a little
bit of time with ryan o'hearn at first
base righty lefty
and a swing and a miss
speltzer picks up strikeout number two
junis 11 for 21 first pitch strikes and
now he's 3-0 and you might want to just
put ceno on here
rosario next yeah well you know wants to
know he's come close a couple of times i
i i'm going to be a little careful with
him might as well put him on it's always
looking to mike matheny you know one
thing that's important if you're in a
3-0 count with a guy a lot of times
you're thinking he's up there he's
taking you cannot give in and just throw
a strike you have to throw a quality
strike and they are going to go ahead
and intentionally walk him yeah i
thought they might just to set up a
force in the bases and mike matheny
coming out jacob went four and two
thirds of his last one and greg holland
will come out of the bullpen here in the
fifth inning so jacob hoping to go five
tonight
goes four and two thirds and then hands
the baseball to greg holland 2-1
minnesota alex gordon leads off the
fifth against devin smelter he's done a
great job tonight
well he knocks one to center field
that'll work
sure will the way they're playing him
that's money so the tying run is at
second base with one out two one
minnesota bottom of the fifth
back up the middle that finds center
field here comes alex gordon he will
score the tying run and lopez comes
through against the lefty
that's what he's waiting for he waited
all that time for something he could
handle and it's a fastball middle look
at that four seamer he waited and he was
rewarded look at the good even swing
going right back up the middle that's a
nice stroke now the go-ahead run is in
scoring position and airfield has been a
very good hitter this year with runners
in scoring position
left field and deep going back his cave
at the wall leaping
he made the catch jk with a great catch
at the wall
taking a three-run home run away from
whitmerfield what a catch by jk
that's a tremendous catch looked like
the ball was going to clear the wall he
caught it right against the top barrier
as mcgroom stands in having flied to
right and struck out tonight oh for two
that
belts it high in the air and that's a
goner home run ryan mcbroom and the
royals have a three to two lead here it
comes again and it's elevated this time
and boom goes mcbroom how about that
second career homer that was beautiful
and he hit his first one in an identical
spot off of kykel the left-hander
he can go deep off lefties and righties
beautiful swing
garber now just won for 20 this year
against right-handed pitching boy this
is the rosenthal that matheny knew so
well when they were together with the
cardinals
he struck him out well here is cruz
he struck him out and the royals win the
ball game by a final score of three to
two
trevor rosenthal what a job man was he
awesome
and the pin to win